Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thank you everyone
that submitted questions for this week’s
Marvel Q&A.
This video is going to be a little extra special
just because some really big stuff is going
on in Hollywood and Robert Downey Jr just
happens to be at the center of it.
So there’s a bunch of cool stuff I wanted
to explain today.
The biggest news of the morning is that Robert
Downey Jr, in his own words, is going to ride
the Iron Man Wave into the shore.
So I’ll explain what that means before getting
to questions.
There are also a few announcements at the
end of the video.
Just to start things off I want to ask everyone
a big question:
“How long is it okay for someone to play
a character?”
Not just in the movies, just in general, animated,
anything anywhere.
There’s no real wrong answer to that, it’s
kind of an unfair question because characters
change all the time, so
Robert Downey Jr’s Iron Man in 2008 is a
completely different person than the Iron
Man we’ll see in Avengers 2 next year.
Second point, the way we engage with them
over time changes a lot too.
And when we get to watch people evolve with
their characters, it helps to keep us engaged.
Robert Downey Jr for all intents and purposes,
just said he’s going to keep being Iron
Man until people stop buying tickets to Iron
Man movies.
Which is never.
How do I think this will play out?
First, as you may have already seen, he’s
using his superhero mega money and his super
fame to fund his own independent films like
The Judge.
You’ll see a lot more of that.
It’s all done through his production company
Team Downey that he and his wife run.
The new model for actors in hollywood now
is to build an audience for themselves on
social media, whether it be facebook, instagram,
youtube and use that audience to develop their
own passion projects.
Some people start building the audience, then
break into hollywood, some do it in reverse.
Like Robert Downey Jr.
He just joined twitter a little while ago
and he even has a facebook page where he’s
been posting original videos.
He’s using that to create awareness for
all these smaller projects he’s working
on.
Vin Diesel is another example of a big hollywood
actor that developed a large audience he shares
his passion projects with.
The last Riddick movie is a good example.
He mortgaged his own house to fund part of
the movie.
Without his facebook fandom, the movie would
have lost money and he would be homeless now.
It’s a really fascinating trend.
So If you guys want me to talk more about
that kind of stuff just let me know.
Because it’s something that really fascinates
me from a creator perspective.
Now let’s answer some of your questions.
I did include some movie stuff, but careful
for spoilers from episode 2 of shield...I’ll
wait just a sec...okay, here we go!
Question 1 - Alex asks, could Fitz be aware
he’s hallucinating Simmons and he’s just
doing it to make himself feel better?
It seems like he knows that other people can’t
see her.
So something weird is going on.
He seems crazy enough that he doesn’t think
he’s crazy to be talking to her.
I think he’s completely at the point of
dissociation with reality that he just accepts
head simmons is there as she exists in his
mind.
That’s why she’s always wearing the same
clothes from season 1.
I don’t think he’s faking anything, I
think it’s an automatic defense mechanism
his psyche conjured up to fill in gaps in
his brain’s normal ability to process information.
Question 2 - J Moe asks, do you think the
blue TAHITI alien brought the obelisk to earth?
Yes, I also think the blue alien in the box
is the TAHITI alien.
Like the one we saw in the tube being pumped
for the secret formula was the one they found
in the crash in 1945.
They’ve just kept some of it’s biological
systems alive so they can extract the genetic
material they need.
Question 3 - Mike asks, Where is Isabelle
Hartley?
We didn’t see her body in the casket?
They’re just leaving it open enough so they
can bring her back if they want.
Remember, Captain America and Nick Fury met
at his burial site.
Don’t assume that a funeral equals dead
forever.
It’s not a guarantee we’ll see her again
this year, but Lucy Lawless said her contract
left all possibilities open.
Question 4 - Yami Jay asks, do you think Coulson
ordered Simmons to infiltrate HYDRA?
I don’t know about Coulson but I definitely
think someone ordered her to do it.
She’s the shinning beacon of goodness on
the team, so I don’t think she’d be inside
HYDRA unless it was for a good reason.
It’s possible she took it on herself to
embed herself, she could be searching for
something, like advanced technology or scientific
information.
Coulson knows everything apparently, so regardless
of why she’s there, he knows.
Question 5 - Aquaneos asks, do you think we’ll
ever get a Spider Woman reference on the show?
I think it’s a weird situation where Marvel
doesn’t have the rights to the spider man
charactes, but the do have the rights to Jessica
Drew and Spider Woman.
I think it has to do with her origins.
There are a lot of legal rules about the use
of “Spider stuff” in marketing materials,
so if Marvel brought her on or referenced
her in some way it would probably be using
her real life name.
They’d say Agent Drew or Agent Jessica Drew.
Question 6 - xm 188 asks do you think they’ll
wait till the finale for skye to meet her
father?
No, I think it will happen before the mid-season
finale and during that episode they’ll activate
or try to use the obelisk in some way.
From a producer’s standpoint.
You want to end the season with a metaphorical
explosion, like a big Oh Shit moment, and
leave people wondering what’s going to happen
after the big bang goes off.
It’s just a technique to keep people interested
until the show comes back.
I think the Agent Carter plot will overlap
with SHIELD this year.
At least one of the stories will overlap with
the obelisk storyline, just because Agent
Carter is going to air in SHIELD’s timeslot
while SHIELD is
on break.
It’s just a powerful way for them to maintain
engagement and get SHIELD fans
to watch
Agent Carter.
Question 7 - Tim asks how did Raina and the
Doctor touch the Obelisk without getting hurt?
I didn’t see Skye’s dad pick it up, but
I thought I heard him reference something
they did with it that changed what it looked
like.
The symbols weren’t quite as visible before
this final scene.
So they did something to it.
Based on what was said it sounds like the
object has a will of it’s own and allowed
Raina to touch it.
I think that only certain meta humans will
be able to use it.
Like Skye for instance.
Expect all of those things to be explained
in episodes which feature her dad.
Question 8 - Mariah asks what if the clockwork
orange device in the teaser for episode 3
was used to ‘condition’ absorbing man?
Yes, definitely.
I think Kraken uses that to brainwash SHIELD
agents into working for HYDRA and getting
information.
It’s just a way for them to control powerful
people.
Don’t be surprised if one or more of the
big characters this season turn out to be
brainwashed.
Like General Talbott.
Question 9 - Bruno asks what if the third
faction is AIM?
Baron Von Strucker did create AIM in the comics
after World War 2.
I’d like to think it’s something new we
haven’t seen yet.
I don’t need everything to be familiar.
But SHIELD does typically draw from things
the movies have already set up.
In the movies AIM wasn’t implied to be HYDRA,
Killian claimed he formed it himself.
And I don’t think he was HYDRA.
So I’m thinking it’s something new.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions.
Lots of cool stuff happening next week so
be sure to subscribe to get my episode 3 video.
Flash and Arrow are both starting too.
Because I’ll be posting Flash videos tuesday
nights, my SHIELD videos won’t post till
super late at night every week.
Like 1 or 2AM wednesday mornings.
That’s pacific time.
SO just adjust based on which time zone you
live in.
I’ll remind everyone next week so no worries.
Right now click here for my episode 2 video
and click here for my episode 1 video.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
I’ll see you tomorrow!